MAX SALTONSTALL: Hey, Steve,
my new app, Moneymaker,
is doing great.
It turns out, a lot of
people want to trade stocks
from their phones.
But now I've collected all these
account numbers and credit card
numbers.
I'm pretty worried
about protecting
all that sensitive
information so I
can maintain the trust
of everyone using my app.
STEVE SOLEIMANI:
It sounds like you
need some additional security.
What if one of your
employees decides
to go rogue and start
their own competition?
MAX SALTONSTALL: Oh, no!
I definitely need to minimize
any data exfiltration,
either from a disgruntled
employee or any attacker.
STEVE SOLEIMANI: Great!
How do you control
data access today?
MAX SALTONSTALL: Well, I've
got some sensitive data.
But it's storage that many
projects have access to it.
I'm really worried about
unauthorized copying going on.
Can you help?
STEVE SOLEIMANI: Absolutely.
I'll show you how a VPC
Service Controls perimeter
can make you more secure.
MAX SALTONSTALL: Great.
STEVE SOLEIMANI: All right.
We've got two projects--
one that has sensitive
data and one that
is attempting to
exfiltrate data.
Each project has its
own storage bucket.
The sensitive storage
bucket is locked down.
And it's only accessible to a
select few service accounts.
For this example, we will
use this service account.
Oh, no!
An attacker gained access
to our service account
and to the sensitive data.
They've added the
compromised service
account to an
unauthorized project
and created a bucket to
exfiltrate data using the cloud
storage API.
Let's take a look.
Here, I'm acting as
the malicious actor.
I copy sensitive data--
account numbers--
from the customer
account data bucket to the
exfiltrated customer data
bucket using the
compromised service account.
The malicious actor copies
the data to their own bucket,
and can now allow access
from outside the company.
MAX SALTONSTALL:
That's bad, right?
How do we protect against that?
STEVE SOLEIMANI: We'll
create a perimeter
with VPC Service Controls.
This lets you lock down GCP
services, similar to how
firewalls protect your servers.
From the console, we'll
go to VPC Service Controls
and select our organization.
This perimeter
controls which projects
can call on the GCP APIs,
specifically allowing
only the ones you choose.
I give it a name--
in this case,
super-exfiltration protection--
then choose the project
I want to protect.
Finally, I'm going to choose
to restrict the storage API.
Any storage API call
coming from outside
that perimeter will fail.
Now, only storage API calls
from inside this project
will be allowed.
Success!
Our data is safe,
or at least safer.
As you can see, you can
use VPC Service Controls
to lock down your projects
and protect sensitive data.
MAX SALTONSTALL: That's great!
I'll go set that up today.
And it keeps me
safe from attackers
inside or outside my company.
STEVE SOLEIMANI: This is
just one of the many tools
that Google Cloud
provides to make
sure your public cloud workloads
stay as private as you need.
MAX SALTONSTALL: Subscribe below
to get more content like this,
and comment with
questions or feedback
so we know what you
want to hear next time.
STEVE SOLEIMANI: Thank
you for joining us.
[MUSIC PLAYING]